the Joe Rogan experience I think we all
know at this point that not everyone's
on an even playing field we're just not
but we don't I think a lot of people
know that well they're [ __ ] crazy and
that's the problem
yeah yes they're [ __ ] crazy if you
don't think that being born in a
crime-ridden neighborhood with violence
all around you and being exposed to at
an early age [ __ ] your head up not even
mean that I think the fact that I admit
that a lot of people aren't hard-working
oh yeah this is that - yeah and like to
say that out there it's shocking to many
people I guess some people are bad some
people think that just because they show
up at work and they don't want to that
they're working hard right right it's
hard for them yeah you [ __ ] you just
got lucky or you do that you know what I
read that was one of the more hilarious
things that I've ever heard of crazy
progressive person right if you are
successful it is because someone else
got [ __ ] over that's so disturbing but
it's such a crazy way to look at it it's
like okay somewhere down the chain or if
you have an iphone someone got [ __ ]
over that someone lost their iPhone
right no no no the logic is someone had
to work as a slave in Foxconn to make
these [ __ ] iPhones for like 15 cents
a week or whatever they make over there
but if that slave wasn't making 15 cents
a week that slave would be dead that's
what there has been saying it's
squirrelly right cuz but yeah but is
that okay
like when they go to third world
countries and set up these sweatshops
and like I knew someone who had one and
they were like doing [ __ ] mental
gymnastics to try to justify and I was
like wait a minute how much he pay these
people and they're like they were gonna
starve to death if it wasn't for us Mike
are you sure they were there right they
were there they're probably there for
thousands of years like where'd you go
like Guatemala where was it Argentina
the grace'
give you two examples that are maybe I
can't speak to specific that's a second
world example okay North Korea which is
obviously my beat yeah that's your B so
there is a zone between North and South
Korea where they work together the DMZ
[ __ ] no but it's like this
enrichment zone it can work together
right so the North Koreans work there
the South Koreans kind of put it
together and the government takes like
95% of your money and also North Koreans
who work in Russian logging camps where
the government takes like 95
they're slaves they're hundred-percent
slaves Wow but they're beating down
their doors to work in these locations
because they're providing for their
family and they're still wealthier than
the alternative now this is a very
extreme situation this isn't like god no
third world what country your friend is
a sweatshop in but there are
circumstances where a lot of people on
the left and on the right don't
understand often that politics and
economics is about often you have two
bad choices like what is the alternative
it's like what do you like for example
you're gonna put forth the law what are
you gonna do about people who are going
to look at this law not in good faith